[موسيقى]
يا له من عدو ماكر هكذا قالت هكيام
والمعارك تشتعل في كبد السماء الاوكرانيه
وفي احشاء المحيطات واما اردوغان فيتدخل
بالوساطه المخابره الامريكيه اوكرانيا
ستمحى من العالم بينما توجه بولندا ضربه
قاسيه للاوكران والمدد يصل كيافمين
بلغاريا واضافه للطائره اوكرانيا تطلب
سلاحا امريكيا اخر لحسم المعارك واشنطن
تفرض شروطا لذلك وبيلاروسيا تضع خطه
جهنميه لتثبيت الاوضاع الروسيه في
اوكرانيا والجزائر ترفع الفيتو امام فرنسا
من اجل انقاذ النيجر وماكرا يتوعد
بالانتقام ومجلس الانقلاب يجد طريقه
للالتفاف على عقوبات الايكواس فيما عاود
طباخ بوتين الظهور في ساحه لحرب روسيه
جديده وفي السودان الدعم السريع يوجه صفعه
غير مسبو للجيش اعلان ساعه الصفر لم يكن
هناك هدوء يسبق العاصفه بل اندلعت عاصفه
المعارك الضاريه فورا وها هي تتواصل في
الفتره
الاخيره خسائر تزداد وهنا اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان مقاتله الروسيه دمرت
زورقا امريكيا سريعا من نوى
كان يحمل مجموعه انزال اوكرانيه شرقيه
جزيره الافعى بالبحر الاسود الى ذلك اضافت
الوزاره الروسيه ان مقاتله تابعه لاسطول
البحر الاسود دمرت زورق استطلاع اوكراني
اقترب من منصات استخراج الغاز الروسيه في
البحر الاسود كما احبطت الدفاعات الروسيه
جائره استهدف العاصمه موسكو ومقاطعه
بريانسيك جنوب غربي روسيا وما كل هذه
الهجمات والرد عليها الا البدايه حيث اكدت
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه دخول وحدات
اوكرانيه الى قريه روبوتين جنوبي
زابوريجيا كما اشارت الوزاره بان
المقاتلين الاوكرانيين ينظمون عمليات
اجلاء للسكان المدنيين في القريه وذلك تحت
قصف مدفعي روسي لا يتوقف واليكم المصدر
كما اعلنت نائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
انا مليار دخولها وحدات اوكرانيه تابعه
للواء الميكانيكي المنفصل السابع
والاربعين الى وسط قريه روبوتيني جنوب
زابوريجيا وقالت مليار ان المقاتلين
الاوكرانيين في هذه الوحدات ينظمون عمليات
اجلاء للسكان المدنيين في القريه وسط قصف
مدفعي روسي في محاوله لاستعاده المواقع
التي فقدتها موسكو في المنطقه
فيما اعلن الجيش الاوكراني ان روسيا نفذت
ضربتين صاروخيتين واكثر من اربعين غاره
جويه وخمسه واربعين هجوما بمنظومات
الصواريخ على مواقع للقوات المسلحه خلال
24 ساعه وتابع الجيش الاوكراني انه يواصل
سد الهجمات الروسيه الشرقيه البلاد متقدما
باتجاه ميليتوبال لتعود الدفاع الروسيه
وتعلن الحصيله وذلك باعلانها صد الهجوم
الروسي 14 هجوما شنته قوه كياب وتكبيدها
اكثر من 700 قتيل وتدمير عشرات المدرعات
والدبابات خلال يوم واحد والعهده على
المصدر والذين تصفحه امامكم في الموقع
الرسمي للحكومه الروسيه هنا اعلن وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني اوليكس عن توقعه بان
تطول الحرب في اوكرانيا وان قوه بلاده
ستتعرض للمزيد من الخسائر المؤلمه واصفا
روسيا بالعدو الماكر والقوي فهل هي رساله
مبطنه للغرب ام انه يقول الحقيقه ولا غير
لا ارادت سلطاتك يا فيت تحالف مع النيتو
حربا حقيقيه مع روسيا وما حقيقه كخيال يا
ساده ومع كل هذا الضغط الروسي والضربات
القويه ضد القيام اعلن البينتاجون ان على
اوكرانيا في عدد من الشروط قبل ان توافق
الولايات المتحده على تزويدها بطائره اف
16 المقاتله امريكيه الصنع وقالت نائبه
المتحدث باسم البينتاغون صابرينا سينغ في
بيان لها يوم الاثنين ان تسليم الطائره
لجهه الثالثه يتطلب مراعاه بعض المعايير
بما في ذلك تعلم اللغه الانجليزيه وغيرها
من الامور مثل الامور اللوجستيه على الارض
برايكم هل هي شروط سهله لياتي هنا ما هو
اسهل من الطائرات حيث اعلن وزير الدفاع
البلغاري تودور تجاريف ان بلاده
[موسيقى]
للغرب مجددا
وذلك عن استعداد روسيا للعوده الى صفقه
الحبوب في حال الوفاء الحقيقي بالالتزامات
تجاه الجانب الروسي من جهتها افادت مصادر
في الرئاسه التركيه بان الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان سيزور روسيا لاجراء محادثات مع
نظيره الروسي فلاديمير بوتين حول صفقه
الحبوب وعلى ذات السياق جاءت الضربه لكياف
والغرب من بولندا هذه المره حيث عن
استعدادها لفرض حظر على استيراد الحبوب من
اوكرانيا بعد الخامس عشر من سبتمبر عام
2023 ياتي هذا بعد ان اصبحت بولندا المنفذ
الوحيده للصادرات الزراعيه الاوكرانيه عقب
توقف صفقه الحبوب فلما تتركون جيرانكم
جائعين ايها البولنديون ومن بولندا ننتقل
الى الجره الاخرى بيلاروسيا حيث كشف تقرير
امريكي من خلال وثائق مسربه عن خطه جهنميه
تتبع هميان حليفه موسكو الوثيقه بهدف
الترويج لروسيا داخل اوكرانيا سنوات طويله
وتدريب اطفال من عده مدن اوكرانيه وفق
صحيفه
اي ان الحلفاء يغرسون حب روسيا في صغار
الاوكران وكما يقول المثل التعليم في
الصغر كان نقش على الحجر
الاحداث والتطورات اصدر رئيس الوزراء
اليابانيته باتخاذ جميع الاجراءات اللازمه
فيما يتعلق بخطه كوريا الشماليه اطلاق قمر
صناعي والاستعداد لحاله غير متوقعه والى
النيجر حيث كشفت الاذاعه الجزائريه عن ان
الجزائر رفضت طلبا فرنسيا لفتح مجالها
الجوي امام عمليه عسكريه في النيجر واضافت
الاذاعه ان الجزائر تعارض اي تدخل عسكري
اجنبي في النيجر المجاوره وتفضل اتباع
السبل الدبلوماسيه لاستعاده النظام
الدستوري بينما افادت قناه ارتي الروسيه
بان النيجر بدات مباحثاتها لايجاد طرق
جديده لتجارتها بعد العقوبات الاقتصاديه
التي عليها المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا ايكواس وذلك عبر الجاره الحليفه
بوركينا فاسو عبر الحدود المشتركه ومن جهه
اخرى وبعد طول غياب ظهر
قائد مجموعه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
مقطع فيديو ملمحا فيه الى وجوده في
افريقيا حيث ظهر في منطقه صحراويه مؤكده
ان فاجنار تسعى لجعل افريقيا اكثر حريه هل
صارت النيجر هي الهدف القادم لفاغنر اعلنت
قوات الدعم السريع تحقيق ما سمته نصرا
كبيرا في معسكر سلاح المدرعه جنوب الخرطوم
وتكبيد الجيش السوداني خسائر فادحه في
الارواح والعتاد ونجاحها في السيطره على
اجزاء واسعه من المعسكر وكميه كبيره من
العتاد والذخائر في المقابل اعلن الجيش
السوداني صد محاولات اقتحام متكرره نفذتها
قوات الدعم السريع لمقر سلاح المدرعات
ومجمع الذخيره في الخرطوم حذرت وكاله
الانباء الرسميه في كوريا الشماليه من ان
تدريبات العسكريه المشتركه بين كوريا
الجنوبيه والولايات المتحده قد تؤدي الى
حرب نوويه حراريه